have you ever find yourself in High  Point North Carolina and nothing was  safe  come on down to doug duggart's brazilian  jiu jitsu you will learn to tackle and  grapple like an Ultimate Fighting pro in  my studio you get hands-on training take  on multiple enemies this is a tap that's  a grapple this is a tap that's a grapple  [Music]  all ladies learn to protect yourself and  your loved ones there are many different  levels  there's the beginner level and if you  pass my private one-on-one sensei prom  you may make it into the advanced class  does our Brazilian Jujitsu at the high  point mini mall just piece of a piece of  bar on two doors down from Kyle's  discount wheels and furniture so quick  taco dip their trip ups right no stakes  their way special discounts for college  students move it  [Music]  you